This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In April 2018, a group of engineers and designers gathered on a dock in the Port of Everett in Washington state. They were there to hear from a 56-year-old inventor and entrepreneur, the creator of the Titan submersible. As a child, Stockton Rush had dreamed of becoming an astronaut. Less than perfect eyesight quashed those plans, and he wasn't interested in simply going along on a rocket ride. I didn't want to go up into space as a tourist, he told a reporter. I wanted to be Captain Kirk on the Enterprise.
这里是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。2018年4月，一群工程师和设计师聚集在华盛顿州埃弗雷特港的一个码头上。他们是来听取一位56岁的发明家兼企业家、“泰坦”号深海潜水器创造者的演讲的。斯托克顿·拉什在孩提时代曾梦想成为一名宇航员。由于视力不够完美，这个计划破灭了，而且他对单纯作为游客搭乘火箭上太空并不感兴趣。“我不想当太空游客，”他曾对一名记者说，“我想成为企业号上的柯克船长。”
I wanted to explore. So he turned his attention to another mysterious realm, the depths of the ocean. He founded a company, Ocean Gate, with the aim of ferrying passengers thousands of feet underwater where they could view the wreckage of the Titanic. He led the design of the Titan, casting himself as an innovator, unconstrained by convention. Instead of encasing his entire vessel in titanium, as was the industry practice for submarines, he built its hull out of lighter-weight carbon fiber. I think it was General MacArthur who said, you're remembered for the rules you break, and I've broken some rules to make this, he said in an interview.
“我想去探索。”于是，他将注意力转向了另一个神秘的领域——深海。他创立了一家名为“海洋之门”的公司，旨在将乘客送往数千英尺的水下，让他们亲眼观赏泰坦尼克号的残骸。他领导了“泰坦”号的设计，将自己塑造为一个不受传统束缚的创新者。他没有像潜水器行业的惯例那样用钛合金将整个船体包裹起来，而是用重量更轻的碳纤维建造了船体。他在一次采访中说：“我想是麦克阿瑟将军说过，你因打破的规则而被人们铭记，为了制造这个，我打破了一些规则。”
The carbon fiber and titanium, there's a rule you don't do that. Well, I did. When experts outside and inside his company raised concerns about safety, he brushed them off. Standing on the dock in the Port of Everett on that day in April, he boasted, we know more about what's happening in this hull than anyone has ever known. The voyage of the Titan, he added,
碳纤维和钛合金，这是规定不能混用的。嗯，我用了。当公司内外的专家对安全性提出担忧时，他不屑一顾。那天4月，他站在埃弗雷特港的码头上吹嘘道：“我们对这个船体内部发生的事情的了解程度，超越了以往任何人的认知。”他接着说，“泰坦”号的航行
will be one of the great moments of submersibles. He turned to Tony Niesen, Ocean Gate's director of engineering, who lifted a bottle of champagne and smashed it against the hull. And with this, I thee christen Titan. and smashed it against the hull. And with this, I decristen Titan. Woo!
将成为潜水器发展史上最伟大的时刻之一。他转向“海洋之门”工程总监托尼·尼森，托尼举起一瓶香槟砸向船体。“我以此命名你为‘泰坦’。”砸向船体。“我以此命名你为‘泰坦’。”呜！
Five years later, Stockton, Rush, and four passengers were killed instantly when the Titan imploded on a deep sea dive. For centuries, philosophers and theologians have warned us about the dangers of hubris. It's an emotion that can make us arrogant, egotistical, and reckless. This week on Hidden Brain, the double-ledged sword of pride. They say that pride goes before a fall. It's a warning that many of us have been taught from the time we were children. Watch out, our parents and teachers have told us, being prideful is a bad thing.
五年后，“泰坦”号在一次深海下潜中发生内爆，斯托克顿·拉什和四名乘客瞬间身亡。几个世纪以来，哲学家和神学家一直在警告我们傲慢的危险。这是一种会让我们变得傲慢、自负和鲁莽的情绪。本周的Hidden Brain节目将探讨：骄傲是一把双刃剑。人们常说，骄傲使人落后。这是我们许多人从小就被灌输的警告。我们的父母和老师告诉我们，要注意，骄傲是一件坏事。
At the University of British Columbia, psychologist Jessica Tracy has spent many years thinking about whether that warning we've all heard is too broad. Jessica Tracy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. It's really great to be here. Jessica, you found yourself drawn to the story of a man named Dean Carnassus. Who was Dean Carnassus? What was he like as a teenager and a young man? Yeah, this is a really interesting story. So Dean grew up in California, Southern California, and he was a pretty active guy.
在英属哥伦比亚大学，心理学家杰西卡·特雷西花了很多时间思考，我们听到的这个警告是否过于笼统。杰西卡·特雷西，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我来。很高兴能来到这里。杰西卡，你发现自己被一个名叫迪恩·卡纳西斯的人的故事吸引了。迪恩·卡纳西斯是谁？他作为一个青少年和年轻人时是什么样的？是的，这是一个非常有趣的故事。迪恩在加利福尼亚州、南加州长大，他是一个相当活跃的小伙子。
He ran on the cross-country team, and he loved it. And he describes running along the beach every day and chasing waves with a coach that just kind of really encouraged in the team a love of running, right, much more than competitiveness. But at some point before Dean graduated high school, unfortunately, the coach retired. Dean did not like the new coach.
他参加了越野队，并且非常热爱这项运动。他描述了自己每天沿着海滩跑步，和教练一起追逐海浪的经历，教练在团队中培养了一种对跑步的热爱，而不是强烈的竞争意识。但是，在迪恩高中毕业前的某个时候，不幸的是，教练退休了。迪恩很不喜欢新教练。
He was much more of a sort of a hard type guy who blew whistles a lot. And so Dean quit and he basically stopped running for kind of the next 10 to 15 years. And then he found himself as an adult working in business. He was in sales, he was pretty successful, doing pretty well. But somehow he had this sense that something wasn't right. On the morning of his 30th birthday, Dean Karnasis woke up with a conviction that his life was on the wrong track. Something was not the way that he wanted it to be. And he wasn't sure what that was, right?
他更像那种吹着哨子的严厉型教练。于是迪恩退出了，在随后的10到15年里，他基本停止了跑步。后来，成年后的他发现自己在经商。他做过销售，相当成功，干得挺不错。但不知为何，他内心总觉得有什么地方不对劲。在他30岁生日的早晨，迪恩·卡纳西斯醒来时坚信，他的人生走错了方向。有些事情并不是他想要的样子。而且他并不确定那到底是什么，对吧？
He sort of just felt this sense of, there's something missing here. I feel a sense of emptiness. And what he told his wife was, I feel like I'm in a routine, you know, as many of us feel when we have a job and it's going well. And he'd been succeeding, he'd just gotten a new deal kind of secured and was on his way to getting a good promotion. But what he saw was a future where 30 years from now, he was doing exactly the same thing, only as he put it, a lot older and maybe balder. And it wasn't what he wanted. So that same night he went out drinking with his friends and something happened
他只是有一种感觉，“这里好像缺了点什么。我感到一阵空虚。”他对妻子说：“我觉得自己陷入了日常的泥潭中，”你知道的，就像我们许多人拥有一份进展顺利的工作时的感觉那样。他一直很成功，刚刚敲定了一笔新交易，正准备晋升。但他看到的是30年后的未来：自己依然在做着完全相同的事情，只不过正如他所说，老了许多，可能也更秃了。这不是他想要的。所以当天晚上，他和朋友们出去喝酒，发生了一件事
at the nightclub that night. Tell me that story Jessica. Yeah so he goes out to celebrate his 30th birthday as many people do. His wife goes home early, she's tired and after she leaves an attractive stranger starts flirting with him. He's his 30th birthday, as many people do. His wife goes home early, she's tired, and after she leaves, an attractive stranger starts flirting with him. He's obviously a little bit buzzed and flirts back. And he's happily married, but all of a sudden he realizes what he's doing is reaching for something,
那天晚上在夜总会里。给我讲讲这个故事，杰西卡。好的，就像许多人一样，他出去庆祝自己的30岁生日。他妻子累了，先回家了。她离开后，一个有吸引力的陌生女子开始跟他调情。他迎来了30岁生日，就像许多人一样。他的妻子累了，先回家了，在她离开后，一个有吸引力的陌生女子开始跟挑逗他。他显然有点喝高了，也回以调情。他婚姻美满，但突然之间他意识到，自己现在是在渴望某种东西，
and this is not what he wants to be reaching for. He immediately leaves the nightclub, goes home to his home in San Francisco, digs through his garage and finds this old torn-up pair of running shoes that I think he uses for gardening at the time, puts them on, and just starts running. And he ends up running, I mean at this point it's almost midnight, runs from his house and ends up running all night long, 30 miles down the the coast all the way to Half Moon Bay. And you know he hasn't run mind you in at least 10 years prior. He finds himself at one point on the top of a mountain and he can see you know over the
而这并不是他真正想要渴望的东西。他立刻离开夜总会，回到他在旧金山的家，在车库里翻找出一双破旧的跑鞋——我想他当时是用来做园艺的——穿上它，然后开始奔跑。他开始跑，我的意思是当时已经快半夜了，从他的家里出发，一路跑了一整夜，沿着海岸跑了30英里，一直跑到了半月湾。要知道，他在此前至少10年里都没有跑过步了。有那么一刻，他发现自己站在山顶上，能够越过
fog and the stars and all of a sudden he pauses and he realizes that in that moment he feels more himself and more alive than he has in years. If you look carefully at Dean's past, what he did that night was not entirely out of character. Indeed, you could say that the career path he was on was not entirely out of character. Indeed you could say that the career path he was on was what was out of character. This is a guy who when he was 12 got on his bicycle and biked from his parents house somewhere in Los Angeles to his grandparents house in Pasadena. Took him 12 hours and he had no idea, 12 years old, he had no idea how to do that. So basically it
雾气和繁星看到远方，突然他停下脚步，意识到在那一刻，他感到了前所未有的真实的自己，感到了前所未有的活着的活力。如果你仔细审视迪恩的过去，他那天晚上的行为并非完全不符合他的性格。实际上，你可以说他当时所处的职业道路才是
was a matter of winding through random neighborhoods until he found ones that looked right. This is the kind of person he was, right, sort of seeking adventure and not only not afraid of pain that comes with doing hard work but actually almost seeking it out, that somehow the pain of physical exercise, physical struggle, was the thing that really gave him a sense of wholeness. And that's what he was looking for, and it's what he found that night on his birthday. The midnight run transformed Dean's outlook. I asked Jessica what changes came about as a result of his epiphany. Well, after recovering from the strenuous run, he realized this is what he wanted to be doing.
真正不符合他性格的东西。这家伙在12岁时就骑上自行车，从他位于洛杉矶某处的父母家骑到了帕萨迪纳的祖父母家。花了他12个小时，而且他当时只有12岁，根本不知道该怎么走。所以基本上就是
He ended up quitting his job, his very successful business career, taking a major leap of faith, you know, saying to his wife, listen, this might be economically hard on us for a little bit, but this is what I need to do. And he ended up devoting his life to running. He became what is known as an ultra marathon runner, which means he runs distances longer than a marathon's 26 miles quite regularly. And he ended up running all of the longest races in the world, right? These are hundred mile races, I think several hundred mile relay races.
在随机的街区里穿行，直到找到看起来对的路。他就是这样的人，对吧，有点像是在寻找冒险，不仅不害怕做苦工带来的痛苦，甚至几乎是在主动寻找这种痛苦，某种程度上，身体锻炼和身体搏斗带来的痛苦，才是真正让他产生完整感的东西。这正是他在寻找的，也是他在那个生日之夜找到的东西。这场午夜奔跑彻底改变了迪恩的人生观。我问杰西卡，他的顿悟带来了哪些改变。嗯，在从剧烈的奔跑中恢复过来后，他意识到这正是他想要做的事情。
He did one of those entirely himself. You're supposed to switch and have teams do it. And instead he just ran the whole thing. He ran through a desert at one point. And many of these races he actually won. He ended up writing a book about his experiences called The Ultramarathon Man. And the book was so popular and influential that he ended up getting named Time Magazine, one of the most influential people in the year. And he really changed people's lives. I mean, I think many, many people read this book and realized, okay, maybe it's not running for me, but there's something in
他最终辞去了工作，放弃了他非常成功的商业生涯，纵身一跃，对妻子说：“听着，这在经济上可能会让我们艰难一阵子，但这确实是我必须去做的事。”他最终将自己的人生奉献给了跑步。他成了一名所谓的超级马拉松运动员，这意味着他经常进行长达26英里马拉松标准距离以上的长跑。他最终跑遍了世界上所有最长的比赛，对吧？这些都是百英里的比赛，我想还有几次几百英里的接力赛。
here that I also need to do, right? That my life also is not going the way that it feels like it should be going. Even though everything's going perfectly well, there's something missing. I also need to take the leap that Dean Karnazes took. I understand that his longest race ever was 350 miles and to complete it he ran continuously for three days and nights without sleep. That's insane Jessica. It is insane. I agree. I don't know honestly I don't know how he does it. He tells funny stories about calling on his cell phone to order a pizza delivery and he tells the pizza delivery guy, I will be at a particular location in an hour,
他独自跑完了其中一场。这种比赛本该轮流交替由团队完成。但他却一个人跑完了全程。他甚至还在某个时候穿越了沙漠。其中的许多比赛他实际上还赢了。他最终写了一本关于自己经历的书，名叫《超级马拉松先生》。这本书如此受欢迎和具有影响力，以至于他被《时代》杂志评为当年的年度最具影响力人物之一。他真的改变了人们的生活。我的意思是，我认为许多许多人读了这本书后意识到，好吧，也许跑步不适合我，但里面确实有一些东西
bring me the pizza. And the guy brings him the pizza literally on the road in the middle of the night. He then proceeds to eat it right out of the box, holding the box in one hand, grabbing slices with another, while running the whole time. ["The Trial of the Heart"] So Dean says that when people hear his story, they often have a couple of questions. What are these questions?
也是我需要去做的，对吧？我的人生也并非完全按照它应该有的感觉在前进。尽管一切都进展得完美无瑕，但似乎还是缺少了点什么。我也需要像迪恩·卡纳西斯那样纵身一跃。我听说他跑过的最长比赛是350英里，为了完成比赛，他连续三天三夜不睡觉地奔跑。这太疯狂了，杰西卡。确实很疯狂。我同意。老实说，我不知道他是怎么做到的。他讲了一些有趣的笑话，比如在跑步时用手机叫披萨外卖，他告诉送披萨的人：“我会在一小时后到达某个特定地点，
Yeah, so the first question is how, right? How do you do this? And that involves all kind of technical details like training and ordering food on the run. But then the second question, which I think is the much more interesting question, and he says is the much harder question to answer is why. Why would someone possibly put themselves through this much pain? What are you trying to get out of this? And I agree, that's a really interesting question.
把披萨带给我。”而那个人真的在半夜的大马路上把披萨送到了他手上。接着他就直接站在路边吃了起来，一只手拿着披萨盒，另一只手抓着披萨片，一路跑个不停。["内心的审判"] 迪恩说，当人们听到他的故事时，通常会有几个问题。这些问题是什么？
What do you think the answer is? Does he know the answer? What Dean would say, I believe, is it's what he needs to do to be the person that he believes he is. And I agree with that. What I think is that Dean is looking for a feeling of pride, right? It's a feeling that doesn't come automatically just because we're succeeding in ways that our society tells us we need to pride, right? It's a feeling that doesn't come automatically just because we're succeeding in ways that our society tells us we need to succeed, right? He was
是的，第一个问题是如何做到的，对吧？你是怎么做到的？这涉及到各种技术细节，比如训练以及在奔跑中订购食物。但第二个问题——我认为是有趣得多的问题，也是他说最难回答的问题——是“为什么”。一个人怎么可能会让自己经历这么大的痛苦？你到底想从中得到什么？我同意，这是一个非常有趣的问题。
a successful business person. He was supporting his family. He was getting promotions at work, but he wasn't being the person that he saw himself to be. He wasn't meeting his own goals for his identity. And that's what we all need to be. And that's what brings us pride. And I think all of us, when we're not getting that, we know it. So if you look down history, philosophers and theologians have long warned us about the dangers of pride.
你认为答案是什么？他知道答案吗？我相信，迪恩会说，这是他为了成为他坚信的那种人而必须做的事。我对此表示赞同。我认为迪恩是在寻找一种骄傲感，对吧？这种感觉不会仅仅因为我们取得了社会告诉我们要达到的那种成功而自动降临，骄傲感，对吧？这是一种不会仅仅因为我们以社会要求的方式取得成功而自动降临的感觉，对吧？他曾
Can you tell us a little bit about that long tradition and what these thinkers have had to tell us? Yeah, it's really interesting. If you look historically, almost every early thinker talked about pride as essentially a sin. Clearly, what they're talking about is the pride that makes people feel like they're better than others.
是一名成功的商人。他供养着家庭。他在工作中不断晋升，但他并没有活成他眼中的自己。他没有达到自己对自我身份认同的目标。而这正是我们所有人都需要去做的。这正是带给我们骄傲感的东西。我想我们所有人，当没有得到这种感觉时，心里都是清楚的。因此，纵观历史，哲学家和神学家长期以来一直警告我们骄傲的危险。
It makes people arrogant. It makes the people behave in a way that we all find really off-putting. They are superior, they take control. No one really likes that. And I think there's reasons why it doesn't fit with a kind of religious perspective, which is probably why every religion, including Buddhism, Taoism, they've all said that pride is really problematic. History is replete with stories about prideful people who ended up wrecking their lives and the lives of the people around them. Prideful military leaders have led armies to catastrophic defeats.
你能给我们讲讲这个悠久的传统以及这些思想家对我们说了些什么吗？是的，这非常有趣。如果你从历史来看，几乎每一位早期思想家都把骄傲本质上视为一种罪恶。显然，他们所谈论的是那种让人觉得自己比别人优越的骄傲。
Prideful entrepreneurs have led their companies to bankruptcy. Prideful acquaintances and co-workers are unpleasant to be around. In the case of Dean Karnazes, the ultra marathon man, pride led to almost mythical feats of strength and endurance. How can the same emotion be responsible for such radically different outcomes? When we come back, research into how pride actually comes in two flavors, and how these two kinds of pride lead us in very different directions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The writer and philosopher John Ruskin said pride was at the bottom of all great mistakes.
它让人变得傲慢。它让人们的行为举止让我们所有人都感到非常反感。他们高高在上，掌控一切。没有人真正喜欢这样。我认为这也是它与某种宗教视角格格不入的原因，这大概也就是为什么每一个宗教，包括佛教、道教，都认为骄傲确实是个大问题。历史充斥着关于骄傲自大的人最终毁了自己和身边人生活的故事。骄傲的军事领袖曾带领军队走向灾难性的失败。
The Italian poet Dante Alighieri said pride was the deadliest of the seven deadly sins. Buddhists say pride is one of the ten feathers that shackle individuals to an endless cycle of suffering. At the University of British Columbia, psychologist Jessica Tracy says those warnings miss the fact that there is more than one kind of pride. There is certainly the pride that drags us down, but also a version of pride that pulls us up. Jessica, you say we fundamentally misunderstood
骄傲的企业家曾将他们的公司带向破产。骄傲的熟人和同事让人相处起来很不愉快。但在超级马拉松运动员迪恩·卡纳西斯的案例中，骄傲却催生了近乎神话般的力量与耐力。为什么同一种情绪会导致如此截然不同的结果？稍后我们将探讨关于骄傲其实有两种不同的风味，以及这两种不同的骄傲如何引导我们走向截然不同的方向的研究。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。作家兼哲学家约翰·罗斯金曾说，骄傲是一切重大错误的根源。
the emotion of pride. We've long thought of it as being one thing, when actually it's two things, one good, one bad. You say the good version is something you call authentic pride. What is authentic pride? Yeah, so authentic pride is the pride that we feel when we've worked really hard for something that's important to us, meaning important to our identity, how we see ourself, sort of think about your best version of yourself
意大利诗人但丁·阿利吉耶里曾说，骄傲是七宗罪中最致命的一宗。佛教徒则说，骄傲是束缚个体陷入无休止苦海轮回的十羽之一。英属哥伦比亚大学的心理学家杰西卡·特雷西表示，这些警告忽略了一个事实，即骄傲不止一种。确实存在将我们拉入泥潭的骄傲，但也有一种将我们托举向上的骄傲。杰西卡，你认为我们从根本上误解了
and how you wanna be in the next few years or even a lifetime, you put an effort to be that person, whether that's working really hard at school or at your job, or even in a hobby, maybe there's an artistic pursuit, maybe you're a runner like Dean Karnazes. And when you succeed, you feel this intense sense of achievement.
骄傲这种情绪。长期以来，我们认为它只有一种，而实际上它有两种，一种是好的，一种是坏的。你说好的版本是你所谓的“真实骄傲”。什么是真实骄傲？是的，真实骄傲是我们为对我们重要的事情付出巨大努力后所感受到的骄傲，这里的“重要”是指对我们的身份认同、我们如何看待自己很重要——试着想想你心目中最好的自己，
The feelings that people describe when they have it are things like, I feel accomplished, I feel productive, I feel a sense of self-worth. That's what authentic pride is. So in some ways, all the things that you're pointing to reflect the fact that when we are doing difficult things, they often require long periods of sacrifice. Can you talk a moment about the role that authentic pride plays in our capacity to work hard toward future goals?
以及你希望在未来几年甚至一生中成为什么样的人——你付出了努力去成为那样的人，无论是在学校还是工作中努力工作，甚至是在爱好上，也许是一项艺术追求，也许你像迪恩·卡纳西斯一样是个跑步者。当你成功时，你会感受到一种强烈的成就感。
Absolutely. The reason that we work hard to discover, to innovate, to persist, is because we want to feel good about ourselves. That is authentic pride. It is that feeling that pushes us to be the best that we can be. And if you think about it,
人们在拥有这种体验时所描述的感觉包括：我感到自己很有成就，我感到自己很有成效，我感到了一种自我价值感。这就是真实骄傲。所以在某种程度上，你所指出的所有事情都反映了这样一个事实：当我们做困难的事情时，它们往往需要长时间的牺牲。你能谈谈真实骄傲在我们为未来的目标努力奋斗的能力中所起的作用吗？
in almost every individual's life, there's a choice, right? You can kind of do the minimal, make enough money to support yourself, and then sit on the couch and watch TV, or you can do more. And pretty much all of us want to do more. And maybe we don't want to do more at our job. Maybe the job is just the thing that pays the bills.
当然。我们努力去发现、去创新、去坚持的原因，是因为我们想要对自己感觉良好。这就是真实骄傲。正是这种感觉推动着我们去成为最好的自己。如果你仔细想想，
And our art is the place where we feel good about ourselves. And that's where we put in more. Maybe our family or raising a child or being a good partner. There's lots of different ways that pride can express itself and that we can find our way of fulfilling these needs that we have to be a good person. But everyone has that need. ["Pride is the Most Important Thing in Our Lives"]
在几乎每个人的生活中，都有一个选择，对吧？你可以选择做最少的事情，赚刚好够养活自己的钱，然后坐在沙发上看电视；或者你可以做得更多。基本上我们所有人都想做得更多。也许我们不想在工作中做得更多。也许工作仅仅是那个用来付账单的事情。
Just as personal pride can cause us to make sacrifices to achieve long-term goals, pride in our communities can encourage people to make sacrifices for each other. I think that our identity exists not just in the personal level but also the group level. And so for example Canadians, many Canadians are very proud of being a Canadian. And the result is that we care not just about how our own individual self succeeds but how our group succeeds. What does the group do?
而我们的艺术创作才是那个让我们自我感觉良好的地方。那是我们倾注更多心血的地方。也许是我们的家庭、抚养孩子或是做一个好的伴侣。骄傲可以表现为许多不同的方式，我们可以通过各种方式来满足自己成为一个好人的需求。但每个人都有这种需求。["骄傲是我们生命中最重要的事情"]
And we therefore invest in the group, right? We vote in a certain way because we say, I want the group to go for these social policies that are really important to me or support these particular efforts to help people. And all that's because this is part of our identity. All of us are the beneficiaries of authentic pride. Jessica believes that many of humankind's greatest scientists and artists were fundamentally driven by the desire to experience this emotion. One example, she cites, is the painter Paul Gauguin, who's a famous Impressionist artist. He did these amazing pictures of Tahitian women. And he's a really interesting story because he lived in Paris and during the Impressionist, I guess, Renaissance,
正如个人骄傲能促使我们为实现长期目标做出牺牲一样，对我们群体的骄傲也能鼓励人们为彼此做出牺牲。我认为我们的身份认同不仅存在于个人层面，也存在于群体层面。比如加拿大人，许多加拿大人为身为加拿大人感到非常自豪。其结果是，我们不仅关心我们个人是否成功，还关心我们的群体是否成功。群体做了什么？
when all these Impressionist artists like Monet and Van Gogh were all kind of hanging out. And he got really into that scene, but that's not what he did. He was a very successful businessman, kind of like Dean Curnazis. And he moved to the suburbs, and he was living this very bourgeoisie life, but then he would sneak off into the bohemian areas of Paris where all the artists were hanging out, and he would just be kind of fascinated
因此我们投资于群体，对吧？我们以某种特定方式投票，因为我们说：“我希望群体去支持那些对我很重要的社会政策，或者支持这些旨在帮助人们的特定努力。”这一切都是因为这是我们身份认同的一部分。我们所有人都是真实骄傲的受益者。杰西卡认为，人类历史上许多最伟大的科学家和艺术家，其核心驱动力都是渴望体验这种情绪。她举的一个例子是画家保罗·高更，他是著名的印象派艺术家。他画了许多精彩的塔希提女性画作。他是一个非常有趣的故事，因为他住在巴黎，正值印象派的——我猜是文艺复兴时期，
by what was going on there. He began painting himself, realized that that was really what he loved, and eventually realized he couldn't live what to him felt like a split life, right? On the one hand being this bourgeoisie businessman, on the other hand, really kind of identifying with the more bohemian artist world.
当时所有这些印象派艺术家，如莫奈和梵高都在四处游荡。他非常喜欢那种艺术圈的氛围，但这并不是他当时做的事。他曾是一个非常成功的商人，有点像迪恩·卡纳西斯。他搬到郊区，过着非常资产阶级的的生活，但随后他会偷偷溜进巴黎充满波西米亚风情的地区，那里聚集着所有的艺术家，他只是对
So he quit his job, moved to Paris, had no job, had no money, for a while was kind of starving on the streets, classical starving artist. But he did that because presumably that was what he needed to do. He had to give up what society had demanded of him and do something completely different and live a much more difficult life. You see that humans not only feel pride internally, but we also display it visibly so others can see that we're feeling it. And when someone displays pride, we automatically grant them a different kind of social status. Talk about this research, Jessica. Yeah.
那里发生的事情着迷。他开始自己画画，并意识到这才是他真正热爱的，最终他意识到自己无法过那种在他看来是分裂的生活，对吧？一方面做着资产阶级商人，另一方面内心却真正认同更具波西米亚风格的艺术家世界。
So we've done a bunch of studies showing that pride is associated with a distinct nonverbal expression. So when people feel pride, they show it. They show it in their bodies as well as their face. They tilt their heads up a little bit, they smile a little bit, but they expand themselves. They make themselves bigger. They kind of puff up, right? Their chest gets pushed out, their shoulders are pulled back.
于是他辞了工作，搬到巴黎，没有工作，没有钱，有一段时间像流浪街头的古典艺术家一样食不果腹。但他这么做是因为这大概正是他必须做的事。他不得不放弃社会对他的要求，去做一些完全不同的事情，过上一种艰难得多的生活。你发现人类不仅会在内心感受到骄傲，还会将其明显地表现出来，以便别人能看到我们的感受。当一个人表现出骄傲时，我们会自动赋予他们一种不同的社会地位。聊聊这项研究吧，杰西卡。好的。
Often their arms are extended out, raised above their head or hands on hips. And yeah, in fact, we found that when people show this expression, other people who see them have this unavoidable automatic tendency to see them as higher status. They kind of can't help it. You also ran another study that looked at how the expression of pride changes how we are perceived during job interviews. Tell me about that work. Yeah, so it's interesting when you show a pride expression during an interview, you are more likely to be seen as high status. And you're generally more likely to be hired as well.
我们做了一系列研究表明，骄傲与一种独特的非语言表达有关。所以当人们感到骄傲时，他们会表现出来。他们通过身体和面部表现出来。他们会把头微微扬起，微微一笑，但他们会舒展身体。他们会让自己显得更高大。他们会挺起胸膛，对吧？他们的胸口挺出去，双肩往后拉。
It's complicated because you show too much pride in that interview. People take it as the bad kind of pride. And so it's this really tight balance people have to manage because there is this other side to pride that, as you noted, scholars throughout history have talked about. The classic distinction is between the person who subtly pushes out their chest,
通常他们的手臂会伸展开来，举过头顶或者双手叉腰。而且，是的，事实上，我们发现当人们表现出这种表情时，看到他们的其他人会产生一种不可避免的、自动的倾向，认为他们拥有更高的地位。他们几乎控制不住自己。你还做过另一项研究，探讨了骄傲的表达如何改变我们在求职面试中的被感知方式。聊聊那项工作吧。好的，有趣的是，如果你在面试中表现出骄傲的表情，你更有可能被认为具有较高的地位。而且你通常也更有可能被录用。
demonstrates confidence, speaks in a confident tone of voice, you know, isn't afraid to say their ideas and speak up. That's all good. When it gets to the point of bragging, talking excessively about all your accomplishments, going beyond the subtle displays of pride to more grandiose sort of taking up a lot of space, looming over someone else, you know, really expanding your body in various ways that are necessary, that's where it starts to veer into more problematic pride. So we've talked at some length about authentic pride, but you've made a couple
这很复杂，因为如果你在面试中表现出过多的骄傲，人们会认为这是那种不好的骄傲。因此，人们必须把握好这个非常微妙的平衡，因为正如你所注意到的，历史上学者们一直在讨论骄傲的另一面。典型的区别在于：一个人含蓄地挺起胸膛，
of mentions about this other kind of pride which is hubristic pride you call it. How would you define hubristic pride, Jessica? So hubristic pride is, in short, a sense of arrogance, right? It's the feeling not just that I feel good about myself, but that I'm better than you, right? And I'm better than most people. The words or the feelings that people describe when they feel it are things like arrogance, egotism, cocky, smug, pretentious. These are all feelings that people do have and we all have them from time to time,
表现出自信，用自信的语调说话，你知道的，不害怕说出自己的想法并大声表达。这些都是好的。当它发展到吹嘘的程度，过度谈论你所有的成就，超越了微妙的骄傲表现，变成了一种更夸张的姿态——比如占据很大的空间、居高临下地俯视别人，你知道的，以各种不必要的方式过度舒展身体——这就会开始滑向更有问题的骄傲。我们已经详细讨论了真实骄傲，但你之前也提到了另一种骄傲，你称之为傲慢自大的骄傲。杰西卡，你将如何定义傲慢自大的骄傲？简而言之，傲慢自大的骄傲就是一种傲慢感，对吧？这种感觉不仅是我对自我感觉良好，而是“我比你强”，对吧？“而且我比大多数人都强。”当人们感受到这种情绪时，他们所描述的词语或感觉包括：傲慢、自负、自大、沾沾自喜、自命不凡。这些确实是人们会有的感觉，我们所有人有时也都会有，
but they're not feelings that are particularly socially adaptive. We don't like people who show these feelings. We don't like people who admit to them even. And yet they are part of the human experience. Jessica once came by powerful examples of authentic and hubristic pride when she asked two students to describe their accomplishments and how their accomplishments made them feel. describe their accomplishments and how their accomplishments made them feel. A student who rated words high in authentic pride, they talked about winning the all league honor on their soccer team and what they said was, you know, I worked really hard and I
但它们并不是特别具有社会适应性的感觉。我们不喜欢表现出这些感觉的人。我们甚至不喜欢承认自己有这些感觉的人。然而它们又是人类体验的一部分。杰西卡曾遇到过真实骄傲和傲慢自大骄傲的强有力例子，当时她让两名学生描述他们的成就以及这些成就带给她们的感受。描述她们的成就以及这些成就带给她们的感受。一名在真实骄傲相关词汇上得分较高的学生，谈到了他们在足球队中赢得全联盟荣誉的经历，他们说：“你知道的，我付出了非常努力的劳动，并且
felt really good about myself. All that hard work had paid off. That's classic authentic pride. I mean, that is really that's exactly what it is. You work hard, you get the achievement and the achievement makes you feel pride in such a way that you're very focused on the effort that you put in, which again is reinforcing of that effort. The motivation then is there to put that effort in again in the future.
我对自己的感觉非常好。所有的努力都得到了回报。”这就是典型的真实骄傲。我的意思是，这确实就是那回事。你努力工作，你获得了成就，而成就让你感到自豪，这种自豪感让你非常专注于你所付出的努力，而这反过来又巩固了这种努力。于是，未来再次付出这种努力的动力便由此产生。
Now we had this other undergrad who scored high on the words that indicate she'd been feeling a lot of hubristic pride. And what she said was, I found out I got a 4.0 GPA. I obviously found other people to try to tell my score to as many as I could because I wanted to share my success. And I think that's a really nice example because that is what hubristic pride makes people wanna do. It makes us not just think, wow, I feel really good.
现在我们有另一位本科生，她在表示自己感受到大量傲慢自大骄傲的词汇上得分很高。她说的是：“我发现自己得了4.0的GPA。我显然找了其他人，尽可能多地把我的成绩告诉他们，因为我想分享我的成功。”我认为这是一个非常好的例子，因为这就是傲慢自大骄傲驱使人们去做的事情。它不仅让我们觉得：“哇，我感觉真好。
I work so hard. You know, no, she's saying, where can I find other people to tell this to? And of course that's what I want to do, right? I obviously wanted to mention my success. And that's hubristic pride. It makes us want to brag. It makes us want to get attention from others
我付出了这么多努力。”不，她在说：“我在哪里可以找到其他人来告诉他们这个消息？”当然，这正是我想要做的，对吧？我显然想提及我的成功。这就是傲慢自大的骄傲。它让我们想要吹嘘。它让我们想要从别人那里获得注意力，
to kind of relive the pride experience, not by having more achievements, but by publicizing it as much as possible. Would it be accurate to say that in some ways authentic pride is a more internal kind of pride and hubristic pride might be more of an external kind of pride? You know, they're both internal experiences, but I think you're right that with hubristic pride, there is this really strong motivation to share it with others by bragging often. That said, I also think this is where authentic pride can slip into hubristic pride.
不是通过取得更多的成就，而是通过尽可能多地公开它，来重新体验那种骄傲的感觉。说真实骄傲在某种程度上是一种更内在的骄傲，而傲慢自大的骄傲可能更偏向外在的骄傲，这种说法准确吗？你知道，它们都是内在的体验，但我认为你说得对，对于傲慢自大的骄傲来说，确实存在一种通过经常吹嘘来与他人分享的强烈动机。话虽如此，我也认为这正是真实骄傲滑向傲慢自大骄傲的地方。
I think anytime we feel pride, we all have this automatic desire to maximize the feeling. It's a really good feeling, possibly the best feeling it is, because you not only feel good, you feel good about yourself, right? This thing that you care about more than anything else has just done something that makes you feel awesome. And so right away we think, okay, how do I make this last? How
我认为每当我们感到骄傲时，我们所有人都有这种自动最大化这种感觉的渴望。这是一种极好的感觉，可能是最棒的感觉，因为你不仅感觉良好，而且对自我感觉良好，对吧？这个你比什么都在乎的东西刚刚做了一件让你感觉棒极了的事情。所以我们立刻会想：“好吧，我该如何让这种感觉持久？我该如何
do I continue it? And one easy way that we've all learned is tell someone else because they're gonna congratulate you, they're gonna tell you how awesome you are, that's gonna maximize and lengthen and extend those feelings. The problem is, depending on who you are, that's going to maximize and lengthen and extend those feelings. The problem is, depending on who you tell, depending on how many people you tell, and depending on how you tell it, that's where it can risk sliding into hubristic pride. I understand that you and others have examined whether there are personality differences associated with these two kinds of pride.
延续它？”而我们都学会的一个简单方法就是告诉别人，因为他们会祝贺你，他们会告诉你你有多么棒，这将会最大化、拉长并延伸那些感受。问题是，取决于你把这件事告诉了谁，取决于你告诉了多少人，以及取决于你是如何告诉他们的，这正是它可能面临滑向傲慢自大骄傲风险的地方。我听说你和其他人曾研究过这两种骄傲是否与不同的个性差异相关。
What have you found? Yeah, they're really different personalities. It's quite interesting and quite stark. So people who tend to feel heuristic pride tend to be what I would call a much darker personality than people who tend to feel authentic pride. People who tend to feel authentic pride basically have all the good personality traits.
你们发现了什么？是的，它们的个性特征截然不同。这非常有趣且极其鲜明。因此，倾向于体验傲慢自大骄傲的人往往拥有我所说的比倾向于体验真实骄傲的人黑暗得多的性格。倾向于体验真实骄傲的人基本上具备所有良好的性格特质。
They're extroverted, they're agreeable, they're conscientious, so they're hardworking, they're really achievement motivated. They also tend to be good relationship partners. They care about others. They care about being helpful to others. People who tend to feel hubristic pride show none of those traits.
他们外向、随和、有责任心，这意味着他们工作努力，有着极强的成就动机。他们往往也是很好的恋爱伴侣。他们关心他人。他们关心如何对他人有所帮助。倾向于体验傲慢自大骄傲的人则不具备上述任何特质。
They basically are disagreeable. They're often unconscious, so they don't actually work all that hard. And they're not particularly good in relationships. They don't have the same kind of empathy for others that people high in authentic pride do and they tend to be selfish. They also tend to engage in behaviors that we would even call immoral or potentially socially problematic. They're Machiavellian, so they sort of are willing to take advantage of others for their own benefit. They can be selfish, they can be hostile and they can
他们基本上很难相处。他们往往缺乏责任心，所以实际上工作并没有那么努力。他们在人际关系中表现也不是很好。他们不像高真实骄傲的人那样对他人抱有同理心，而且往往很自私。他们还倾向于从事我们甚至可以称之为不道德或潜在具有社会问题行为。他们是马基雅维利主义者，也就是说他们为了自身利益甘愿占他人便宜。他们可能很自私、充满敌意且具有
be aggressive. I understand that you have induced both authentic pride and hubristic pride in volunteers in lab experiments and found that these different kinds of pride produce very different downstream behaviors. Like what, Jessica? Yeah, so you know it's not easy to induce, I will say, hubristic pride, especially in Canada, I should say, where there's a lot of social regulation of hubristic pride. It's not an accepted thing to feel at all in Canada. The norms are all about humility. So you see people really trying to veer away from it. But if we push and we say,
攻击性。我听说你在实验室实验中通过诱导志愿者的真实骄傲和傲慢自大骄傲，发现这两种不同的骄傲会产生截然不同的后续行为。比如什么，杰西卡？是的，你知道，要诱导出傲慢自大的骄傲并不容易，我要说的是，尤其是在加拿大，我想补充一点，因为在加拿大对傲慢自大的骄傲有着大量的社会规范约束。在加拿大，这根本不是一种被接受的感受。社会规范全都是关于谦逊的。所以你会看到人们极力想要避开它。但如果我们强力推动，说：“
come on, everyone's felt this way at some time, we sometimes can get it. And what we'll find is people are more willing to do things like show prejudice against out-group members. They demonstrate lower empathy for others. They essentially become more likely to engage in these kinds of behaviors that are characteristic of people who are prone to hubristic pride,
来吧，每个人在某个时候都有过这种感觉，”有时我们还是能诱导出来的。我们发现的是，人们会更愿意做出诸如对群外成员表现出偏见之类的事情。他们对他人表现出较低的同理心。他们本质上更有可能从事那些倾向于傲慢自大骄傲之人的典型行为，
which is basically putting others down, showing low empathy for others, being aggressive. And in one study we even found, they will go ahead and cheat on a test if doing so gives them a higher status. So we put people in this situation where they have to complete a puzzle task and then they have to tell a partner
也就是基本上贬低他人、对他人缺乏同理心、具有攻击性。在一项研究中甚至发现，如果这样做能给他们带来更高的地位，他们会在测试中作弊。我们将人们置于这样一种情境中：他们必须完成一个拼图任务，然后他们必须告诉搭档
how well they did on the task, but they first find out how the partner did and the partner did really well, far better than they did. And what we find is that people who are high in hubristic pride will at that point lie about their own score. They will make it better than it actually was because they're so concerned about status and how they look to others. They'll do what it takes to maintain face,
他们在这个任务上做得有多好，但在那之前他们先知道了搭档的表现，而搭档做得非常好，远远超过了他们。我们发现，高傲慢自大骄傲的人在那个时候会隐瞒自己的真实得分。他们会把分数说得比实际更好，因为他们太在乎地位以及自己在别人眼中的形象了。他们会不惜一切代价来维持面子，
essentially. You also ran an experiment where you had volunteers play the role of judges and you presented them with an unusual scenario and also then induced authentic or hubristic pride. Tell me about the study and what you found. Yeah, so we gave them a crime that's sort of a victimless crime. It was prostitution, which is illegal in most states, most provinces in Canada.
本质上就是这样。你还做过另一个实验，让志愿者扮演法官的角色，向他们展示一个不寻常的场景，然后诱导他们产生真实或傲慢自大的骄傲。聊聊这项研究以及你的发现吧。好的，我们给他们设定了一个相对而言属于无被害人犯罪的罪名。那是卖淫，在大多数州、加拿大大多数省份都是非法的。
But of course, it's unclear that there's a victim here. And so you could see a situation where people really want to go kind of gently on the prostitute who's been arrested. And what we found is that that is the case, but when people were first manipulated to feel hubristic pride, they were much harsher, so much more punitive.
但当然，这里是否存在受害人并不明确。所以你可以看到这样一种情况：人们真的很想对被捕的性工作者宽大处理。而我们发现的情况确实如此，但当人们最初被操纵去体验傲慢自大的骄傲时，他们会变得严厉得多，惩罚性也强得多。
What do you think that is saying? I think that when people feel hubristic pride, they become motivated to make themselves better than others in any way that they can, right? They wanna demonstrate their superiority over others. And this is one way of doing it, right? It's sort of an easy target. Go after people who are weaker than you, who seem different than you, and attack them and then you feel good about yourself.
你认为这说明了什么？我认为，当人们体验到傲慢自大的骄傲时，他们会被驱使着用任何可能的方式让自己高人一等，对吧？他们想要展示自己对别人的优越感。而这正是做到这一点的方法之一，对吧？这是一个容易下手的目标。去攻击那些比你弱小、看起来与你不同的人，攻击他们，然后你就会自我感觉良好。
When we come back, how to harness the power of authentic pride. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Jessica Tracy is a psychologist at the University of British Columbia. She's the author of Pride, The Secret of Success. She argues that when we see the emotion of pride only as a negative thing, we miss out on all the powerful ways. Pride can also be a driver of determination, sacrifice, and pro-social behavior.
稍后我们将探讨如何驾驭真实骄傲的力量。你正在收听的是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。杰西卡·特雷西是英属哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。她是《骄傲：成功的秘密》一书的作者。她认为，当我们仅仅将骄傲的情绪视为负面事物时，我们就错失了骄傲能够发挥强大作用的所有途径。骄傲同样可以成为决心、牺牲和亲社会行为的驱动力。
In your book, Jessica, you write about a very interesting study of how the experience of pride affected people who are trying to lose weight on a diet. Tell me about that study. Yeah, this is a cool study by Will Hoffman and colleagues. They basically had a sample of Germans who were trying to resist various temptations like, you know, eating a delicious piece of chocolate cake when they were on a diet. And we all know this is really challenging. I think everyone's been there at some point. And what they found is that when those people were told, hey, next time you want to eat that chocolate cake, before you do, remember how much pride you felt last time you resisted temptation.
杰西卡，在你的书中，你写了一项非常有趣的研究，关于骄傲的体验如何影响那些试图通过节食减肥的人。聊聊那项研究吧。是的，这是威尔·霍夫曼及其同事做的一项很酷的研究。他们基本上找了一组德国受试者，这些人正试图抵制各种诱惑，比如（你知道的）在节食时克制自己不吃一块美味的巧克力蛋糕。我们都知道这非常具有挑战性。我想每个人在某个时刻都曾经历过。他们发现，当告诉这些人：“嘿，下次你想吃那个巧克力蛋糕时，在动口之前，先想想上次你抵制住诱惑时感到了多么自豪。”
And so the people would do this and it actually worked, right? The people who actually reported feeling more pride the last time they resisted temptation were better able to resist temptation next time. It's kind of amazing, it's such a sort of easy shortcut, but it does actually work. You also say that when we do something we are not proud of, when perhaps we feel shame about how we've acted, a desire to feel pride again can motivate us to make
于是人们照着做了，而且真的奏效了，对吧？那些报告说上次抵制诱惑时感到更骄傲的人，在下一次更能成功抵制诱惑。这简直太神奇了，这是一种非常简单的捷径，但它确实管用。你还说过，当我们做了一件让我们不引以为傲的事情时，当我们或许为自己的行为感到羞愧时，渴望再次感受骄傲的心情可以激励我们做出
amends. Now this doesn't have to be about, you know, making earth-shattering discoveries. It can be about the pride we take in being a good friend or a good parent. I understand that you have some experience with this also as a parent. Yeah, absolutely. Hopefully this is something every parent can identify with, but we all have those moments, I certainly do, where we take our own stuff out on our kid and then feel horrible about it. For me, this happened some years ago. My daughter was 11 and I was going through a hard time. And
弥补。这不一定非得是什么惊天动地的大发现。它可以是身为好朋友或好父母所感到的自豪。我理解作为父母，你在这方面也有一些经验。是的，完全如此。希望这是每个父母都能感同身受的，但我们都有过这样的时刻——我肯定有过——把自己的情绪发泄在孩子身上，然后感到内疚万分。对我来说，这发生在几年前。我女儿当时11岁，我正经历一段艰难的时期。而且
there was one day where I forget what happened, but something had happened that I was in a particularly bad place emotionally and I had to take her to softball practice. And she, as 11 year olds do, was not ready on time and took too long getting her shoes on. And so we were running late and I lashed out at her. You know, I said something like you really need to get your act together. You know, this is you've got to you know, you're 11 now. You've got to be more responsible, get your stuff together. And she's the kind of kid who just takes all that and just like internalizes it completely, you know. And so I immediately felt she felt horrible.
有一天，我忘了具体是因为什么，反正发生了点事，我的情绪处于一个特别糟糕的状态，我得带她去垒球训练。而她呢，正如11岁的孩子那样，没有按时准备好，系鞋子花了太长时间。于是我们时间紧迫，我便对她发火了。你知道的，我说了一些类似“你真得好好振作一下了”之类的话。你知道的，这……你得……你知道的，你现在11岁了。你得更有责任感，把自己的事情做好。而她是那种会把这些话全盘接受并完全内化的人，你知道的。所以我立刻觉得，她当时一定难受极了。
I felt horrible. It was probably the worst car ride to softball practice we've ever had. She then, I dropped her at the practice and I spend the next hour feeling awful, feeling like, oh, I just made her feel so bad, she didn't do anything wrong, this is my own stuff, I hope she has a good practice, just really kind of ruminating about it. And so as soon as I pick her up, I say to her,
我感觉糟糕透了。那可能是我俩去垒球训练的路上经历过的最糟糕的车程。后来我把她送到训练场，在接下来的一小时里我一直感觉糟透了，觉得自己刚才让她那么难过，她又没做错什么，这完全是我自己的情绪问题，我希望她训练能顺利，心里一直在翻来覆去地琢磨这事。所以一接她上车，我对她说的是，
okay, I wanna talk about what happened before. And so as soon as I pick her up, I say to her, okay, I want to talk about what happened before. I got mad at you, but you didn't deserve it at all. I was in a really bad place emotionally, and I took it out on you, and that wasn't cool, and I'm really sorry, and I'm going to really try not to do that. And it's okay for you to be mad at me when I do that.
好了，我想谈谈刚才发生的事。所以一接她上车，我对她说的是，好吧，我想谈谈刚才发生的事。我对你发了脾气，但你一点也不该承受这些。我当时情绪真的很糟糕，我把气撒在你身上了，那样做很不应该，我真的很抱歉，我以后会极力避免那样做。如果我那样做的话，你生我的气也是正常的。
And why don't we go and like get cookies at a bakery on the way home. And you know, I feel really good about that because that's kind of the best you can do. You know, I think what often happens when these shaming moments happen is you just push it away, right? I'm never going to think about it again. She and I will never talk about it. I'll pick her up and ask her about practice and we'll pretend it never happened. But by doing this instead, by actually openly talking about it, obviously by the end of practice, I don't know if she still remembered, but it wasn't for her. She wanted to tell me how
要不我们在回家的路上顺便去面包店买点曲奇饼干吧。你知道的，我对这件事感觉很好，因为那是你当时能做到的最好处理方式。你知道的，当这些带来羞耻感的时刻发生时，通常会出现的情况是，你只会把它推开，对吧？我再也不去想它了。她和我绝口不提这件事。我去接她时会问她训练情况，然后我们假装什么都没发生过。但如果反其道而行之，通过真正公开地谈论它，显然到训练结束时，我不知道她是否还记得，但这已经不是为了她了。她想告诉我
the practice went. She didn't want to talk about it. Even when I brought up the apology, she didn't want to talk about it because, you know, 11 year olds are not psyched to talk about emotional stuff. But I think it's really good that we did because it sent her the message that she's not wrong to be upset with me, right? That whatever hurt she was feeling is not on her. That, you know, she's right if she's feeling like that was unfair. And I think it sends the message that, hey, we all make mistakes and that's okay and apologizing is really important. And now that she's a teenager, it's much more often to go the other way.
训练进展如何。她不想谈论这件事。甚至当我主动提起道歉时，她也不想谈论，因为你知道的，11岁的孩子并不热衷于谈论情感方面的事情。但我认为我们这么做真的很好，因为这向她传达了一个信息：她生我的气并没有错，对吧？无论她当时感受到的伤害都不是她的责任。你知道的，如果她觉得那很不公平，她的感觉是对的。而且我认为这传递了一个信息：嘿，我们都会犯错，这没关系，道歉真的非常重要。而现在她已经是个青少年了，事情往往会反过来。
I don't know, teenagers, I think at least 50% of the time come home and are basically jerks to their parents. You know, don't talk to me. And my daughter's great about this, like she's now at a point where she can say, I just can't talk to you for the first hour I'm home and then we'll talk later. So cool, fine. Most of the time, it does not bother me at all because I understand how teenagers work. But every now and then she goes a little far.
我不知道，青少年们，我认为至少有50%的时候回到家里基本上就像个混蛋。你知道的，别跟我说话。而我女儿在这方面很棒，她现在已经能说出这样的话了：“我回家后的头一个小时简直没法跟你说话，等下我们再聊。”这很酷，没问题。大多数时候，这根本不会困扰我，因为我理解青少年的心理。但偶尔她还是会有点过分。
And there was one time recently where she said something and it actually kind of hurt. And I ended up telling her that and she was great. She sent me a text a little while after and just said, hey, I'm really sorry. And I know that's really hard for her to do, but I think setting the example and showing her, if you do that, it really makes a difference. I immediately was like, of course, I forgive you, don't worry about it.
最近有一次，她说了一些话，实际上确实有点伤人。我最后把这告诉了她，而她表现得棒极了。过了一会儿，她给我发了一条短信，上面写着：“嘿，我真的很抱歉。”我知道这对她来说很难做到，但我认为树立榜样并向她展示：如果你这么做，真的会产生不一样的效果。我立刻回复说：“当然，我原谅你，别担心。”
And it really allows you to kind of go on and reinstate that great relationship without having the burden of, oh, there's this thing I did that I feel really bad about and I can't talk about. What is the connection here with authentic pride? So I think it's changing a shame experience into an authentic pride experience, right? I could, you know, knowing me, I tend to really linger on shame things. And so had I not turned that around at the softball practice, I probably would have spent years, probably even to this point, I would still feel bad about that time I lashed out at her before softball.
这真的能让你继续前行，并重建那种极佳的关系，而没有那种“哦，我做过这件让我感觉很糟糕却又无法开口的事”的心理负担。这与真正的自豪有什么联系呢？所以我想，这是将一种羞耻体验转化为一种真正的自豪体验，对吧？我可能会，了解我的人都知道，我往往会对感到羞耻的事情念念不忘。所以如果我当时在垒球场没有扭转局面，我可能会花上好几年，甚至可能直到现在，我仍然会为那次在垒球赛前对她发火的事感到难受。
You know, hopefully not, but I could see it. And instead, if I think about that moment, I think about her little face, you know, when I got mad at her, and that makes me sad. But then I immediately also think, but wait a minute, I fixed it. I feel good about the way that I handle it. That was actually like a good parenting moment. I turn a really bad parenting moment into a pretty good parenting moment.
你知道的，希望不会，但我能想象得到。相反，如果我想起那个时刻，我想起她的小脸，你知道的，当我向她发火的时候，那让我感到难过。但随后我立刻也会想，不过等一下，我把它修复了。我对自己的处理方式感到满意。那其实是一个很好的育儿时刻。我把一个非常糟糕的育儿时刻变成了一个相当不错的育儿时刻。
And that does make me feel authentic pride in my parenting ability. There's an important wrinkle here, which is that the culture and the context that you're in also makes a huge difference. Can you talk about that? Which is that as we express our pride, it's important to pay attention to the context and the culture in which we're in. Speaking about yourself and your achievements in Canada might be different than speaking about your achievements in the United States or in Pakistan. Yeah, no, I think that's really important. And
这确实让我对自己的育儿能力产生了真正的自豪感。这里有一个重要的细微差别，那就是你所处的文化和背景也会产生巨大的影响。你能谈谈这个吗？也就是说，在我们表达自豪感时，关注我们所处的背景和文化是很重要的。在加拿大谈论你自己和你的成就，可能与在美国或巴基斯坦谈论你的成就有所不同。是的，没错，我认为这真的很重要。而且
there's all kinds of interesting cultural reasons for this. I think that a lot of the way that cultures balance their different norms around status and hierarchy is by putting different values on hubristic and authentic pride. But yeah, I think practically speaking, what it means is you need to be really attuned to the context you're in when you express pride. Be really aware of where you are. There are places in America where it is perfectly acceptable to brag about your achievements, where bragging about your achievements can even say, help you get elected president.
这里面有各种各样有趣的文化原因。我认为，文化在平衡其关于地位和等级的不同规范时，很大程度上是通过对傲慢自豪和真正自豪赋予不同的价值来实现的。但是，是的，我认为从实际出发，这意味着当你表达自豪感时，你需要对你所处的背景有很高的感知度。要真正意识到你身处何地。在美洲的某些地方，吹嘘自己的成就是完全可以接受的，吹嘘成就甚至可以说有助于你赢得总统竞选。
But you know in Canada, for the most part, that doesn't fly. Canadians are much more humble. The norms are very different. And then to get even more extreme, there's this great story of the Kalahari Bushmen. In that society, bragging is completely unacceptable. Even just talking about a success is unacceptable. And so an anthropologist there told a story about a hunter he had met. And the hunter said that after he had a big hunt,
但你知道在加拿大，大多数情况下，这一套行不通。加拿大人要谦逊得多。这里的社会规范非常不同。然后，如果更极端一点，有一个关于卡拉哈里沙漠布什曼人的精彩故事。在那个社会里，吹嘘是完全不可接受的。甚至仅仅谈论成功也是不可接受的。因此，那里的一位人类学家讲述了一个他遇到的猎人的故事。这位猎人说，在他经历了一场大狩猎之后，
he would go home, go back to the village, and kind of just sit alone. He wouldn't mention it to anyone. And he would wait for someone to approach him. And when the person approached him and said, Oh, how to go today, he would say, Oh, you know, not that well, I didn't really see a whole lot. And what that would actually do is tell the friend who'd asked him that he'd had a big success, right? Because that's what you do, you sort of force the person to pull it out of you, the friend would then say, Oh, come on, you must have found
他会回家，回到村里，然后一个人静静地坐着。他不会对任何人提起这件事。他会等有人来找他。当有人走近他并问：“哦，今天收获怎么样？”时，他会说：“哦，你知道的，不太好，我其实没看到多少东西。”而这实际上会告诉那个询问他的朋友，他取得了巨大的成功，对吧？因为这就是那里的规矩，你得强迫对方从你口中把话套出来。然后这位朋友就会说：“哦，少来这套，你肯定找到了
something. And then eventually it would come out that he'd had the success. If he had gone back and said, oh my God, I had this big kill, it's so exciting. That would have been a really bad move. It would have made everyone see him as arrogant, as violating the social norms. And because these societies are very strictly organized
什么东西。”然后最终真相才会大白，原来他成功了。如果他当时回来就说：“哦，天哪，我猎获了这么大一只猎物，太让人兴奋了。”那将是一个非常糟糕的举动。那会让所有人都觉得他傲慢自大，违反了社会规范。而且由于这些社会结构有着非常严格的组织形式，
against any strong hierarchy, any kind of hubristic pride is really tamped down. You know, I remember hearing the story, I don't know if it's apocryphal, but some years ago, the Canadian national team, I think, was playing someone else, and this might have been in hockey. And the Canadian team was up, and they were up like four goals to nothing. And I think they scored an extra goal or another couple of goals and people got really mad at them in Canada saying, you're up 4-0. Why in the world would you want to make that 6-0? And of course, in the United States, that would be completely unremarkable.
坚决抵制任何强烈的等级观念，所以任何形式的傲慢自豪都会被极力压制。你知道的，我记得听过这样一个故事，我不知道它是不是杜撰的，但几年前，加拿大的国家队，我想当时是在和别人比赛，这可能是在冰球赛场上。当时加拿大队领先，他们领先了大约四球。然后我想他们又进了一球或是好几球，结果加拿大人对此非常生气，他们说：“你们已经4比0领先了。为什么还要把比分变成6比0呢？”当然，在美国，这会是完全无足轻重的。
They would say, why didn't you go to 8-0? Yeah. I mean, it's interesting that I've been here so long that when you say in the US they would go to 8-0, I'm like, oh, that's terrible. I really internalize those values. Yeah. My daughter's team, when one team is more than five goals ahead of the other, they stop putting them on the board. They just stop counting them. Now the kids keep counting them. Let me be clear.
他们会说：“怎么不扩大到8比0呢？”是的。我的意思是，有趣的是我在美国呆了这么久，当你说在美国他们会想扩大到8比0时，我的反应是：“哦，那太糟糕了。”我真的将这些价值观内化了。是的。我女儿的球队，当一方领先另一方超过五个球时，他们就会停止在记分牌上记分。他们只是不再计分了。现在孩子们还在自己记分，我要说明这一点。
There's no question at the end of the game how many goals were actually scored. But yeah, that's very, don't rub it in. You've won. You've made your point. Don't make the other guy feel bad. Don't hold it over their head is kind of the attitude here. So unwarranted or exaggerated displays of pride can carry social costs, as you've mentioned.
毫无疑问，比赛结束时，双方究竟进了多少球是显而易见的。但是，是的，那种态度就是别往人家伤口上撒盐。你已经赢了。你已经证明了自己。别让对方感到难堪。别把这作为把柄压在别人头上，这就是这里的态度。所以，正如你所提到的，无端或夸大的自豪感表现会带来社会成本。
I want to play for you a bit of tape from the Oscars in 1998. This is tape of the director James Cameron, who is accepting his Oscar for the movie Titanic. There's no way that I can express to you what I'm feeling right now. My heart is full to bursting. Except to say I'm the king of the world! Woo! Woo! Woo, woo, woo!
我想为您播放一段1998年奥斯卡颁奖典礼的录音。这段录音是导演詹姆斯·卡梅隆凭借电影《泰坦尼克号》领取奥斯卡奖时的获奖感言。我无法向大家表达我现在的心情。我的内心充满了狂喜。除了说……我是世界之王！呜！呜！呜，呜，呜！
Ugh. Yeah. It's funny. Even now, I'm like, oof, I can't believe you did that. You know, obviously he's riffing on his own line that he wrote in The Titanic. That's what Leonardo DiCaprio says in a very charming line in the movie. Very charming when Leonardo DiCaprio says it. Not so charming, I would argue, when James Cameron says it after winning a major award.
额。是的。这很有趣。即使是现在，我的反应也是：呃，我真不敢相信你当时那样做了。你知道的，很明显他在模仿自己在《泰坦尼克号》中写过的台词。那是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥在电影中说的一句非常迷人的台词。莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥说的时候非常迷人。但我认为，当詹姆斯·卡梅隆在赢得大奖后说出这句话时，就没那么迷人了。
You know, it's sort of like, why do you have to go there? And I'm sure, you know, the interesting thing about that quote is he has this plausible deniability. If someone says, wow, that sounded really arrogant, his response, I'm sure, would be, oh, I was just quoting my movie. I'm being silly. Of course, I don't think I'm the king of the world.
你知道，这有点像是，你为什么非要扯到那里去呢？而且我敢肯定，关于那句台词最有趣的一点是，他有合理的推诿空间。如果有人说：“哇，听起来真的很傲慢，”我敢肯定他的回应会是：“哦，我只是在引用我的电影。我在搞笑。我当然不觉得自己是世界之王。”
But it's sort of like, well, number one, you wrote that line in the movie. It's not like you're, you know, paying homage to some other movie. You're paying homage to your own movie, which already is a little bit arrogant. But then it's sort of an excuse to allow you to say this thing that your hubristic side really wants to say. I mean, that's really what it is. It's sort of like, I can't help but point out I am the best, which is just such an extreme statement of arrogance.
但这有点像是，第一，那句台词是你写进电影里的。这不像是你在，你知道的，向其他什么电影致敬。你是在向你自己的电影致敬，这本身就已经有点傲慢了。但随后这又成了一个借口，让你能够说出你那充满傲慢自豪感的一面真正想说的话。我的意思是，这其实就是本质所在。这有点像是：我忍不住要指出我是最棒的，这简直是一种极度傲慢的宣言。
And my memory of that is that even among Americans, that was considered a little over the top. You say that one way we can channel our pride in ways that other people won't find obnoxious is to focus our pride in realms that will not threaten other people. I understand that you have a particular pride in your ability to parallel park. I love it that you mentioned that. That shows how much pride I have in it that I'm like, yes, I get to talk about this. Yeah, this is something, you know, I'm just really good at parallel parking. And you can hear in my voice, I can't help, but feel the hubristic pride of it.
我对此的记忆是，即使在美国人看来，这也显得有点过头了。你说过，我们引导自豪感的一种方式是将其聚焦于不会威胁到他人的领域，这样别人就不会觉得讨厌。我听说你对自己的平行停车能力有一种特别的自豪感。我很高兴你提到这个。这表明我对它有多自豪，以至于我的反应是：太好了，我终于可以谈论这个了。是的，这是……你知道的，我平行停车就是特别在行。你从我的声音里就能听出来，我忍不住要为此感到一种傲慢的自豪。
It's a skill, I don't exactly know why I have it, except that my dad made me practice it a million times before my test when I was 16, but that was like a million years ago, so I don't know, it stuck with me. But yeah, I feel really good about it. And I think, you know, probably because I'm not like an athlete, I'm not particularly known for my hand-eye coordination. So it's
这是一种技能，我不太清楚自己为什么会拥有它，只记得在我16岁参加考试前，我爸爸让我练习了上百万次，但那是很久很久以前的事了，所以我不知道，它一直保留在我的记忆里。但是，是的，我对此感觉非常好。而且我想，你知道的，可能因为我不是那种运动员，我的手眼协调能力并不算特别出众。所以这
not something that fits into the rest of my life at all. It's not a domain in which I get any status off of at all. And yet, it makes me feel really good about myself. I used to make my daughter call me the shoehorn. If I was getting into a small spot when she was little, I'd say, Harper, what do you think's going on here? And she'd say, this is a job for shoehorn. I'd say, that's right. My Instagram handle is shoehorn74. So, you know, I really, it's part of my identity.
根本不属于我生活中其他方面的范畴。这不是一个能让我从中获得任何社会地位的领域。然而，它确实让我对自己感觉良好。我过去常让我女儿叫我“鞋拔子”。当她在小时候，如果我要把车停进一个很小的车位时，我会说：“哈珀，你觉得现在是什么情况？”她会说：“这是鞋拔子大显身手的时候了。”我会说：“没错。”我的Instagram账号就是shoehorn74。所以，你知道的，我真的……这已经成了我身份的一部分。
But, you know, what I think is nice about it is, yeah, it feels great. Like there are ways in which when I get into it, I just did it the other day, I got to a spot that was tiny. I was like, did anyone see that? I don't think anyone did, unfortunately. You kind of have this moment of gloating and you feel this real hubristic sense,
但是，你知道的，我认为好的一点在于，是的，这种感觉棒极了。在某些情况下，当我进入状态时——我前几天刚停过一次，我把车停进了一个极小的车位。我的反应是：“有人看到那一幕了吗？”不幸的是，我觉得当时没有人看到。你会有那么一瞬间的沾沾自喜，你会感受到一种真正的傲慢感，
like, wow, I am better than other people at this. And because it's a domain that does not matter at all for my life, right? I don't live in a neighborhood where it's particularly hard to park. I rarely get to show off this skill. And even if I did, it wouldn't matter for my career, my life. There's no way in which this actually matters.
就像：哇，在这方面我比其他人强。而且因为这是一个对我的生活完全无关紧要的领域，对吧？我不住在停车特别困难的街区，我很少有机会炫耀这项技能。即便我炫耀了，它对我的职业生涯、我的生活也毫无影响。这在任何方面都完全不重要。
So it's a safe domain to feel hubristic pride. And I think that's really important. If I felt hubristic pride in my work, that would be really problematic, because I am surrounded all the time by people who do what I do. And when we feel hubristic pride in a domain where our coworkers, our colleagues, our friends are existing in the same world, it can make people feel really bad, right? They don't like it, they feel competitive, they feel jealous.
所以这是一个可以安全地体验傲慢自豪的领域。我认为这真的很重要。如果我对自己的工作感到傲慢自豪，那将是非常有问题的，因为我身边时刻环绕着做我同行的人。当我们在一个与同事、同行、朋友们共享同一世界的领域感到傲慢自豪时，会让人感觉非常糟糕，对吧？他们不喜欢这样，他们会感到竞争心，会感到嫉妒。
And in essence, what you're saying is, I am better than you at this thing we both care about. And that's not a nice thing to say. It's not a thing that's going to help your social relationships. But if I say to my partner, I'm better at you than parallel parking, she's fine with that. So it's okay.
从本质上讲，你想表达的是：在这个我们都在乎的事情上，我比你强。这不是一句好听的话。这不会对你的社会关系有任何帮助。但如果我对伴侣说：“我平行停车比你强，”她完全能够接受。所以这没问题的。
You talked earlier, Jessica, about how authentic pride can sometimes become hubristic pride. And in your book, you give the example of the cyclist Lance Armstrong. Yeah, Lance Armstrong, of course, I think we all know his story a little bit, but it is a really interesting one to think about in this context. He grew up kind of poor family in Texas and wanted to get out of this small town that he lived in and he saw a way out through cycling. He was really into cycling when he was a kid, and by the time he was a teenager,
杰西卡，你刚才谈到真正的自豪感有时如何演变成傲慢的自豪感，在你的书中，你举了自行车手兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的例子。是的，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗，当然，我想我们对他的故事都有所耳闻，但在这种语境下去思考，确实是一个非常有趣的案例。他在得克萨斯州的一个相对贫困的家庭长大，想要离开他生活的那个小镇，他从自行车运动中看到了出路。他小时候就非常热爱骑行，到了青少年时期，
he was biking all the time. You know, after school, all the other kids would go play or, you know, go swimming or whatever. He would be on his bike. He would bike up to 20 miles a day, sometimes 40, and he started entering in these competitions, triathlons, and cycling races, and started winning money. And by the time he was like 16, he
他无时无刻不在骑车。你知道的，放学后，其他孩子都去玩或者游泳什么的。他却一直在骑车。他每天骑车多达20英里，有时甚至40英里，他开始参加各种比赛、铁人三项和自行车赛，并开始赢得奖金。到了16岁左右，他
was winning a lot of money, bringing home something like $20,000 a year for his family, helping support his family through cycling. So this became a huge source of pride for him, right? It was something that he could do that was about the hard work that he put in himself. And it made a real difference and it made people look up to him. He must have felt tremendous authentic pride from that experience. And of course, that carried on. He continued working his butt off, cycling all the time, to eventually become one of the fastest cyclists in the world, winning seven Tour de France races. No one's ever won that many races. And after his seventh, I think it was kind of a unanimous
已经赢得了不少奖金，每年能带回大约2万美元补贴家用，通过骑行帮助支撑他的家庭。所以这成了他巨大的自豪感来源，对吧？这是他通过自己付出的努力所能做到的事情。这带来了真正的改变，让人们对他刮目相看。从那段经历中，他一定感受到了巨大的真正自豪感。当然，这种状态延续下去了。他继续拼命努力，一直不停地骑车，最终成为世界上速度最快的自行车手之一，赢得了七届环法自行车赛的冠军。从来没有人赢得过这么多场比赛。在赢得第七个冠军之后，我想这几乎是一个一致的
decision that across the entire cycling community that he was the best, that there was no one else like Lance Armstrong. And he wasn't just a good cyclist, he was the best, that there was no one else like Lance Armstrong. And he wasn't just a good cyclist, he was a good person. He used his earnings to start this foundation, the Livestrong Foundation, that raised money and awareness for cancer. And he was a cancer survivor and very open about being a cancer survivor. And his foundation was so successful and partly because of his charisma, his own success, his activist abilities, and his cycling abilities, that people everywhere loved him, loved the foundation, everyone wore those yellow bracelets that you don't see anymore but
决定，整个自行车界都认为他是最棒的，没有人能像兰斯·阿姆斯特朗那样。他不仅是个优秀的自行车手，还是个好人。他用赚来的钱创立了这个基金会——“丽芙斯特朗基金会”（Livestrong Foundation），为癌症筹集资金并提高人们的癌症意识。他是一位癌症幸存者，并且非常坦诚地公开自己癌症幸存者的身份。他的基金会极其成功，部分原因归功于他的个人魅力、他自身的成功、他的积极分子能力以及他的骑行能力，以至于各地的人们都爱戴他、热爱这个基金会，每个人都佩戴那些现在已经看不到、但在一段时间里随处可见的黄色腕带。我的意思是，他是一个真正的成功故事。直到当然，我们发现他一直在作弊。
you did see all the time for a period. I mean he was a real success story. Until of course we found out that he had been cheating. He'd been using blood doping so that essentially he kind of did the impossible, right? He won without having it mean anything for his actual ability, right? Usually when we work hard, we win. The reason that feels good is because it tells us, hey, I'm great.
他一直在使用血液兴奋剂，所以从本质上讲，他完成了一项不可能完成的任务，对吧？他在不具备真正实力的情况下赢得了比赛，对吧？通常当我们努力工作并获胜时。这种感觉之所以美妙，是因为它告诉我们：嘿，我很棒。
I just did something that was really important to me and I succeeded. That means I am that person I want to be. But if you're cheating, you can't get that message, right? If you're cheating your way to get ahead, you can win and actually have no idea whether you're the best. Other people think you're the best,
我刚刚做了一件对我非常重要的事情并且成功了。这意味着我成为了我想成为的那种人。但如果你在作弊，你就无法获得这种反馈，对吧？如果你靠作弊来取得领先，你可以赢得比赛，但实际上根本不知道自己到底是不是最棒的。别人认为你是最棒的，
but you don't know if you actually are. And so that's kind of what happened to Lance. The fame and fortune and praise that he got from others became more important to him than his own feeling of, I'm doing this thing that's so important to me, that's making me the kind of person I want to be. And when that gets dissociated, when the desire to get praise and love and attention from others gets separated from the desire to feel good about yourself internally, that's where
但你不知道自己是否真的如此。所以这差不多就是兰斯身上发生的事情。他从别人那里得到的名誉、财富和赞美，变得比他内心的这种感觉更重要：我正在做一件对我如此重要的事情，它正让我成为我想成为的那种人。当这种联系断裂时，当从别人那里获得赞美、爱和关注的欲望，与内心里对自己的良好感觉的愿望分离开来时，这正是
people can engage in things like cheating. I mean, in some ways, the journey you're talking about here is the difference between focusing on an accomplishment versus focusing on others recognizing your accomplishment. That's exactly right. That's exactly right. And it's like I said before, it's easy to do, right? You have a big accomplishment. The first thing you know you feel this incredible surge of pride. The first thing that we all want to feel is how do I make this bigger? How do I keep this going? And the easiest way to do that is to tell other people, right? Get praise from others. And that is the critical decision moment, right? I would say for everyone, that is the moment
人们会陷入作弊等行为的起点。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，你在这里讨论的历程，其实就是专注于一项成就与专注于他人对你成就的认可之间的区别。完全正确。完全正如你所说。就像我之前说的，这很容易做到，对吧？你取得了一项巨大的成就。你首先感到的往往是这股不可遏制的自豪感狂潮。我们所有人首先想要感受的是：我如何把这块蛋糕做大？我如何让它持续下去？而最简单的方法就是告诉其他人，对吧？从他人那里获得赞美。而这正是关键的决断时刻，对吧？我想对每个人来说，那个时刻
where you need to stop, pause, and think about what your goal is, right? Because if your goal is to just kind of get more and more praise, then you're going to veer into hubristic pride. You're going to start thinking more about what others think instead of what you think, right? If your goal is, hey, this is a great moment for me, I want to share it with my partner, I want to share it with my family, I think that's great. You know, I think those are the people that you can share it with.
就是你需要停下来、暂停并思考你的目标是什么，对吧？因为如果你的目标只是为了获得越来越多的赞美，那么你就会走向傲慢的自豪。你会开始更多地考虑别人的想法，而不是你自己的想法，对吧？如果你的目标是：嘿，这对我是个伟大的时刻，我想和我的伴侣分享，我想和我的家人分享，我认为这很好。你知道的，我认为这些就是你可以与之分享的人。
They're not going to judge you for being arrogant. It's not the same as publicizing it to the world. And I think that's probably where the limit is. As soon as you decide to post it on Facebook or Twitter or whatever social media, that's where you're crossing a line potentially, right? Because you can very easily veer into this world that Lance Armstrong veered into where others' views become more important than your own. Jessica Tracy is a psychologist at the University of British Columbia. She's the author of Pride, The Secret of Success.
他们不会评判你的傲慢。这和向全世界公开宣传是不一样的。我想这大概就是界限所在。一旦你决定把它发到Facebook、推特或任何社交媒体上，这可能就是你越界的地方，对吧？因为你很容易滑入兰斯·阿姆斯特朗所陷入的那种世界，在那里，别人的看法变得比你自己的看法更重要。杰西卡·特雷西是英属哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。她是《自豪：成功的秘密》一书的作者。
Jessica, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thanks so much for having me. It's been really fun. Do you have follow-up questions about Pride for Jessica Tracy? If you'd be willing to share your question with a Hidden Brain audience, please find a quiet space and record a voice memo on your phone. You can email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
杰西卡，非常感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。哦，非常感谢邀请我。这真的非常有趣。关于自豪感，你还有什么想问杰西卡的后续问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐秘大脑》的听众分享你的问题，请找一个安静的地方，在手机上录下一段语音备忘录。你可以将其发电子邮件给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再重复一遍邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
Next week in our Emotions 2.0 series, the emotional complexities of mixed feelings. We explore how ambivalence helps us deal with challenging situations and how it can shape our minds. We've done someivalence helps us deal with challenging situations and how it can shape our minds. We've done some research recently where we've shown that feeling emotional ambivalence makes you more cognitively flexible. And what I mean by that is that you not only think about concepts in a more broad and inclusive way, you'll actually process information
下周在我们的“情感2.0”系列节目中，我们将探讨复杂情感的情感复杂性。我们探讨矛盾心理如何帮助我们应对具有挑战性的情况，以及它如何塑造我们的思维。我们最近做了一些研究，表明感到情感矛盾会使你在认知上更加灵活。我的意思是，你不仅以更广泛和包容的方式思考概念，你实际上还会以
in a more cognitively flexible manner. HIDDEN BRAIN HIDDEN BRAIN is produced by HIDDEN BRAIN Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
一种认知上更灵活的方式处理信息。《隐秘大脑》由《隐秘大脑》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。
If you missed our kickoff episode in our Emotions 2.0 series, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's called Emotions 2.0, When I Feel What You Feel. And if you know someone who might enjoy the episodes in this series, we'd love for you to share them. Your recommendations really play a huge role in helping us connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain.
如果你错过了我们“情感2.0”系列节目的首播集，你可以在这个播客动态中找到它。它叫做《情感2.0：当我感你所感》。如果你知道有人可能会喜欢这个系列的剧集，我们希望你能分享给他们。你的推荐在帮助我们将新听众与我们在《隐秘大脑》中探讨的理念联系起来方面，真的发挥了巨大的作用。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。当前这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。